nine times out of ten being a lamb led
to the slaughter is not the best
position to find yourself in that tenth
time however is while playing massive
monsters cult of the lamb a delightfully
demented roguelike that combines
fast-paced engineering bold art dark
topics and real-time simulation elements
to create a one-of-a-kind experience
it couples two popular genres and
smartly avoids their potential pitfalls
all while showcasing the best things
they bring to the table take all this
and add a simple but engaging narrative
and you've got a cult classic game well
worth playing
[Music]
cult of the lamb begins at our poor
titular lamb's end after walking down a
narrow stone corridor you are greeted by
the old gods four monstrous beings to
whom the inhabitants of the strange land
are mostly loyal
as it turns out this little lamb is the
last of its kind having managed to evade
death while the rest of its fluffy
friends were cold the old gods reveal
this was due to a prophecy that a lamb
would be the ones who would lead to
their undoing destroying the old faith
and unleashing the one thing they fear
most the one who waits the gods instruct
their followers to dispatch of you
quickly but little do they know this is
precisely what the prophecy demands upon
being killed you meet with the one who
waits an all-powerful god who we learn
was betrayed and imprisoned by the other
four he then makes you an offer start a
cult in his name and he will both bring
you back to life and gift unto you his
former powers via the red crown
from this point the game divides into
two main sections exploring dungeons and
managing your cult
there are four main dungeons in cult of
the lamb each of them ruled by one of
the old gods the dungeons are composed
of a series of location types arranged
on a web map allowing you to evaluate
their icons and choose the path you wish
to follow the most common types are
combat areas which are denoted on your
map by a sword icon each of these areas
is made up of a handful of randomly
generated rooms occupied by monsters or
if you're lucky a mysterious figure
wielding tarot cards that grant you
various boons other types of areas
include ones filled with resources shops
malevolent pentagram chambers and new
followers
your main objective while exploring
these dungeons is to reach the end and
face off against each of the four old
gods
upon finishing them off all enemy units
grow stronger a new boss enters the
final area and you gain the ability to
venture out repeatedly instead of having
to return to your cult after each
expedition
this adds some major replayability and
gives you the chance to grind when later
areas prove challenging while cult of
the lamb has a fair amount of options
that make it more approachable it is
inherently a fast-paced and challenging
game
though enemies tend to have predictable
move sets rooms can easily become
overcrowded thanks to additional
monsters spawning and all the various
long range attacks more elite units
might throw your way
not only that but like most roguelikes a
great deal of the game is dictated by
chance you have no choice in what weapon
or curse a special attack fueled by
fervor you collect from killing enemies
you begin each expedition with this
randomization is a big factor in what
can be some broad difficulty swings but
it also creates a lot of rewarding
moments when you overcome the drawbacks
you face
there are a few instances where you
might bump into some difficulty spikes
and have a hard time accumulating
resources leading to skill stagnation
and as a result difficulties on
expeditions course correcting isn't too
painful i begin to revisit dungeons and
go to resource-filled rooms rather than
ones filled with enemies or followers
however these moments can be frustrating
while i primarily played cult of the
lamb on normal mode i also tried the
game on both easy and hard to get a feel
for what the differences were i was
happy to find that mechanically
everything stays essentially the same
what is impacted by difficulty is the
size of enemy health bars and the
resources you are given which makes it
ideal to play on a lower difficulty in
order to learn the ropes if you do find
the game getting easier for you or are
feeling overly challenged and need a bit
of a breather you can change the
difficulty back and forth at will
also included in the options you can
quickly adjust are a few helpful
accessibility settings which should help
those who might have motion sickness
visual impairments epilepsy or light
sensitivity while a substantial portion
of the game takes place inside of
dungeons equally as important are the
grassy plains you call home it is here
you are tasked with creating a little
slice of paradise for the woodland
creatures who call you their leader this
includes ensuring they have places to
sleep food to eat and a sanitary
environment
once their basic needs are met your
followers will happily work for you
gathering wood and stone as well as
generating devotion which in turn helps
you upgrade and decorate your compound
also important to your cult success is
their overall faith in you your faith
meter is impacted by how victorious you
are on expeditions as well as how you
treat your cultists interrupting your
followers while they are having a
discussion with one another can cost you
a few faith points whereas conducting a
ritual in your temple involving animal
sacrifice might cause mass disdain if
your faith drops too low your less loyal
followers might start to dissent sowing
seeds of doubt and chaos throughout the
colds you can stave off a potential coup
by attempting to re-educate dissenting
followers or even take them out back and
finish them off though the latter might
lead to even more discontent the most
important building in your commune is
your temple which is where you can
acquire all the upgrades that will help
you on your expeditions
at your temple you can conduct daily
sermons that ultimately unlock permanent
dungeon upgrades you can also use the
temple altar to declare doctrines change
a few key pieces of your build and
conduct rituals declaring doctrines is
where you see the greatest amount of
player choice in the game as you can
decide whether you'd prefer to be loved
or feared by your followers there are
five categories of doctrines you can
choose from each with four guiding
questions that shape how your cult
functions
for example one of these categories is
life and death and poses queries about
how you wish for your followers to view
dying
you can choose to place an importance on
burials
or take a more economical stance and
turn bodies into fertilizer
interestingly enough the game actually
gives you a lot of room to exert some
level of benevolence
if you have no desire to sacrifice your
cultists to the tentacled being that
lies below you don't have to and it
never feels as if you are being punished
or placed at a disadvantage for playing
this way beyond the stretches of your
compound are a few other special
locations with both a dice and fishing
mini game tucked away within them
despite how many pieces and systems
there are in cult of the lamb they come
together in complete cohesion every
mechanic skill tree and system
harmonizes with the resource collection
management and combat aspects of the
game
also working in harmony is the game's
art direction and dark yet playful tone
the woodland creatures that make up cult
of the lamb's cast resembles saturday
morning cartoon characters albeit with
ritualistic markings adorning their cute
and cuddly forms the game uses color
masterfully with certain palettes
designated to certain areas yet
remaining rich and vibrant throughout
the game
the upbeat yet unnerving music is sickly
sweet and creates a distinct contrast
between the cute visuals and the
undercurrent of impending doom
lastly while a plethora of recent games
might have more poignant things to say
about death cult of the lamb offers a
fun and more light-hearted take on the
subject leaning more into chaotic
nihilism
the bulk of its focus is instead on the
acquisition and transfer of power as
well as how easy it is to lose it
naturally these themes take the game
into some dark places but it manages to
do so without ever feeling like it's
trying too hard to be edgy all of these
elements come together to solidify cult
of the lamb as a standout title in both
the roguelike and simulation genres
as well as a one-of-a-kind entry that
exists in the middle of both
whether you are exploring the dungeons
or expanding your cult the experience is
enjoyable challenging and more than a
bit demented with how surprisingly dense
each of these parts are the fact that
all the pieces come together as smoothly
as they do is a triumph
[Music]
[Music]
you